they are the power brokers now after
America's retreat from Syria turkish
President Recep Tayyip Erdogan and
Vladimir Putin met for hours and reached
an agreement they called historic waters
under this operation by removing threats
posed by terrorists guarantees Syria's
territorial integrity and political
unity we never had eyes on Syria's
territory or sovereignty as Turkey all
the steps we have taken in the field we
have taken with sensitivity Syria must
be freed from illegal international
military interference the long-term
stabilization of Syria in general can
only be achieved in our opinion by
observing serious sovereignty and
territorial integrity the Russians and
Turks will patrol the northeast Syrian
border zone together having made sure
it's purged of kurdish fighters deserted
by the US the Kurds have little room to
maneuver in Washington US Secretary of
State Mike Pompeo was insisting the
Trump administration was not responsible
for turkeys invasion of northern Syria
president Trump warned Turkey not to
invade sadly they conducted the
incursion and when President Aaron went
ahead he sent a diplomatic team to try
and avert disaster but this is the
reality American special forces are
retreating jeered and pelted by Kurds
who saw them till recently is liberators
betrayed by America the Kurds have no
choice now but to throw in their lot
with this man Syria's leader Bashar
al-assad striding confidently today onto
land - recently held by rebels and
vowing to take on the Turks invading
from the north
like a motor dyno cool what I want to
say when I call her one a thief is this
he stole the factories and the wheat and
the oil in cooperation with Islamic
state and now he is stealing the land
Russia and Turkey have for now carved up
responsibility for the fraught border
zone and agreed on how to deal with the
Kurds but nothing stays certain in the
Civil War a new reality is emerging but
for how long
Domenic Waghorn Sky News